So how do we improve reliability and availability?
We can try to avoid faults which is about
preventing faults from occurring in the first place.
For example, the no coffee in the server room
is one example of a fault avoidance technique.
If we spill the coffee on a server, that's
probably going to be a fault. So we're trying to
avoid that fault by preventing people from bringing coffee
into the server room. Next, we can have
a fault tolerance technique. They're about preventing faults
from graduating into failures. A typical fault tolerance
technique will use redundancy. For example, ECC can
be used for memory and ECC stands for
error-correcting code. So what happens is if there
is a fault, for example a particle strike, it flips a bit in memory. ECC will
allow us to read that block from memory, realize
that one of the bits has been flipped, and
actually correct that bit. And then we can also
have techniques like speeding up the repair, which really affect
only availability. And an example of such a technique
is when we have a spare hard drive in a
drawer so when a hard drive fails we can
quickly replace it. So this is a technique where basically
the failure will still occur but we will shorten
the period that it takes to repair the system
by basically, in this case, not having to wait
for a new hard drive to arrive. We already
have one handy on site. So we will now
look more closely at the fault tolerance techniques which
are usually techniques that we can apply in computer
architecture to try to prevent faults from becoming failures and
thus, makes systems both more reliable and more available.